North Korea is trying to convince other
governments to condemn president Trump
for vowing to totally destroy his words
the country in his United Nations speech
North Korean state media says the
country sent a letter to foreign
Parliament's calling the president's
threat an intolerable insult the
country's foreign minister said Mr
Trump's word make quote our rockets
visit to the US mainland inevitable all
the more than tracey's following the
escalating crisis from Beijing and good
morning a good morning it is not clear
to which government's North Korea sent
this letter but this does appear to be
part of a new approach in which North
Korea is trying to use president trumps
threats against him North Korea is also
using the president's remarks as
propaganda with its own people over the
weekend they staged a massive
anti-american rally in the capital of
Pyongyang and claimed that 100,000
people showed up now on the same day US
Air Force bombers and fighter jets flew
off North Korea's east coast in a show
of force that the Pentagon says was
designed to show its military options
this is the furthest north on the Korean
Peninsula that u.s. warplanes have flown
so far this century now meanwhile
President Trump continues to refer to
North Korean leader Kim jong-un as
little rocket man despite reports that
the president's aides have warned him
against personalizing this conflict
alright Ben Tracy in Beijing thank you
so much